this
is star talk i'm your host neil degrasse
tyson your personal astrophysicist
and today my special guest
and i really mean special guest
is my 90 year old mother
tony tyson mom
look at me like that well first of all
i'm 90 plus
90 okay that's just for openers and as
you know when
you talk to little children they say i'm
five and a half and i'm six and a half
and i'm seven and a half
and after you get to a certain age you
no longer give your age but when you're
90 you say you're 90 and a half
ninety-nine
people getting those fractions that's
right going on to 91.
okay all right well thanks for agreeing
to do this i had to
twist your arm a little bit you had to
do that i agree and i want you to know
that i hope that um
i'm i hope i'm still around when you
decide to ever
okay if not you can just do it as a
tribute to me
okay we'll just get the editors to go on
fast mode for this
right um i i was interested in
having this interview because you've
lived through so much
having been born in 1929 28.
okay sorry
that's okay okay 1928 right
and so a year before the market crashed
so you're a child in the 1930s
do you what do you remember from that
time a child in new york city
there's just so much to remember but i
certainly don't remember the crash
and we were poor but i didn't you didn't
lose in the stock market your stock
holdings
i'm sure that no one in my family played
the stock market we could hardly speak
english
your portfolio was was unaffected that
is correct you didn't have a portfolio
absolutely and all i remember was that
now i think
i look back i know i realized how poor
we were but i didn't realize we were
poor
we didn't have television to remind us
that we were poor i only knew
the only part of the chicken i knew was
the wing because one chicken was spread
to the whole family and then of course
it'd be soup and other stuff
made from the carcass of the chicken
that is correct but
um i'm a first generation mainland bow
in puerto riquena
my parents are born the in of puerto
rico and my
siblings and my parents are all deceased
now but they were all born in
ottawa where the radio telescope is by
the way radio television and you have
visited that so you
took me to visit it that's right you
were just a kid at that time weren't you
yeah yeah
it had no significance to me at all oh
you know
but i know it meant something to you
mm-hmm so you're
uh you you've told me i don't remember
the details
both of your parents were dead yeah by
the time
you were what age four four so you have
no memory of either of them no i don't
and so i was brought up by two aunts and
uh
they too were born and not as able
and i didn't speak english very well
until i went to public school
and then i had a hell of a time because
here i was my name is suntita feliciano
what kind of name is that
along with everybody else's name who's
jim brown and
so-and-so
had long black hair and this widow's
peak that came down
to my eyes and so i eventually learned
how long was your hair
very long like i would be very
my long hair would have been very
fashionable today except it would be
gray
and then it in addition to that was like
one of the horse's tails
that my daughter owns so that that's
that's that's about it so when did you
meet dad
oh man that's a long time ago we lived
in the same tenement in harlem
in spanish hall on 217 was 111th street
and uh i only remembered my own
addresses how do you remember how do you
mess
ask don't ask me my present address
because
i have long term memory but not
short-term memory at any rate we live in
the same building and then
he went off with his family when he was
about 11 or 12.
and i never saw him again until i was
about 20 or 21.
through a mutual friend of ours a very
dear friend of mine evelyn king
and we met and started dating in the
rest is history
and as a result of that you and stephen
and lynn
were a byproduct and he was just a
byproduct
that's right and so here i am and here
you are
back in spanish harlem there's a point
where you only knew spanish
that is correct and then but that but
that was not
encouraged for you to sort of fit in
so what happened to your spanish well
there was no such thing as
english as a second language so i just
learned english
i just listened to everything and i i've
always been a radio buff
and i listened to the radio a lot and i
learned in my life back then that was
the thing
the radio because that was the only
everybody had a radio no matter how poor
you were yes
it was those arch-shaped radios in the
living room in the living room
and you would sit listen to that and i
would listen to it for hours and repeat
some of the words
okay and that's how i learned some of my
english but that you weren't encouraged
to
sustain the spanish no i know because
multiculturalism is not
supposed to similar assimilate and all
that kind of jazz
that was a thing at that time right so
my earliest memories are in
castle hill housing projects over in the
east bronx
right so you guys were living there
so all housing projects are for people
who who need some kind of
rent assistance fixed income fixed
income right of some kind
correct and so so they have low income
housing projects and
mid-income housing projects in that
world right and we were in the
mid-income housing project that is
correct
right and what was it so did you ha
did you have goals one day we'll move
out of here to somewhere else well the
main thing was the move
that was the name of the game just to
move and we spent about two years there
and then um we had to move because we
needed additional space
and that's when we moved to the bronx to
um
riverdale riverdale yeah we moved
because
my aunt my beloved aunt who raised me
who still did not speak english that
well
was going to move with us so we had a
room for her she was going to move in
with us she was going to move in with us
and then when my aunt died my
mother-in-law moved in with us
so we've always had an older person in
that house and as a result i think the
the three of you neil stephen and lynn
really appreciated having older people
around and have always been
very kind for instance i remember so
distinctly crossing the street with the
three of you
and i don't know whether it was you
stephen stop told us to stop wait a
minute there's a blind person across the
street i'm going to help
11 or 12 years old that i'd never
forgotten that i was very moved so we
waited for him while he went over to get
this person and
and we taught them how to deal with the
blind person
you don't lead them you put let the
person put their hands on your shoulders
and then let them follow you and you
step on this go up the step first so
they'll know there's a step
all those things come back to me so
there's three of us now
my you know lynn me steven
and we're separated by six years so
that's you know that's
tidy enough to to manage i think
because the older one then helps with
the younger one that's enough of a
time gap there did you have any
philosophy you and dad have any
philosophy
of child rearing of course you had the
you had the books you know the no no
forget the books
what okay particularly spark and all
that yeah yeah doctor
was a spot yeah yeah dr spock yeah okay
first of all living in new york city
is like learning living in the middle of
a learning laboratory
everything is there the good the bad and
the ugly
anything your child wants to do is there
for instance
lynn fell in love with horses at a very
early age
she became an urban mounted ranger in
central park as a result of
this experience and then we had stephen
who was an audit
an artist and
he used to live at the metropolitan
museum of art and take classes there
and of course at the modern museum of
art and then you had
neil who was we we introduced to the pla
to the planetarium at a very early age
and that was a fantastic experience for
him
planetarium he used to go to evening
classes there
and as a result of being a new york kid
they could take public transportation
all they needed was a nickel
so dad as uh sociology is his thing
he's working for the city you you by
prior agreement
rather than go to college after high
school you got married
and you became a homemaker
that is correct by agreement what was
the nature of that agreement
the nature of that agreement was the way
to stay home with the children to make
sure that they're taken care of
in addition to that you must remember we
had an older person living with us
and then uh when the three of you were
in three different schools and three
different parts of the city taking
public transportation
i was always concerned about the three
of you getting home safely at any rate
shortly after
stephen went off to college that's when
i went back to school i worked
at fordham university got my my
undergraduate degree
then went to at fordham and then got my
as like a
as like an adult oh yes
degree so after i got my my bachelor's i
went to columbia university
and got my master's in in uh gerontology
services to the elderly and from there i
started my career in working with the
elderly population i directed programs
in
queens i was also
worked for the brookdale center on aging
which was a research
and program run by hunter college do you
think all this
exposure you had to aging people and
tending to them
that sensitize you to this need in
society and it's a cultural thing too
um taking care of older people has
always been a part of my family history
okay so here you are with very
significant
um investment of energy for the
aging there was dad out there concerned
about
youth in the ghetto as of course inner
city was known back then
and you have this sun called neil
who his brain is nowhere in any of those
places
is just thinking about the universe was
that just weird
to you no it was not if that was you
want to do it that's what you did
and if you want to go to the planetarium
here's a dime take the bus
it was not weird at all it did all three
of you went in the direction that you
wanted to go in
as for that i was thankful so
so did you have any pl i mean what was
your plan
as parents raising children other than
keeping us alive
oh yes sir you kept us alive and you
exposed us to everything in the city
that was the plan the great plan was
that hopefully
that as a result of being exposed to
this what i call
learning laboratory of new york that you
choose your professions and pursue it
separately everybody goes on different
directions
so you didn't have any urge for us to
become
a germanologist no no no no no no no no
no sociologist no no no no no no as a
matter of facts piece
i mean homework time at home was quite a
feat
because i had to keep the three of you
separate so you wouldn't talk
and you would be in one place fooling
around with the lights and fixing the
lights and
so that when you walk in the room the
lights came on with music that was your
your pastime
so um if i remember correctly lynn
was in the brownies and girl scouts and
steve was in the boy scouts
but i wasn't in either so because did
you make some jokes
you played baseball yeah you played that
i was
yeah right they weren't they didn't do
that no they didn't do that but you did
the little league
so just a matter of having an activity
that is correct i made sure you were
busy
all the time anything you would have
done differently given the wisdom of 90
years
no i have i have no regrets i have them
and if i did it's too late anyhow
so just get on with life okay so people
who relive their lives and say i should
have done this i should have done this i
may have
come on please just get on with it take
care of the here and now
just do the best you can now now is the
time to do the best you can
can you reflect on the state of race
today relative to back
it's worse it's worse than i've ever
seen is it right yeah it's scary and of
course you you hear everything
it gets the point where sometimes i
can't even watch television because it's
one that racial attack after the other
i mean the attack on the synagogue the
the the the
what's happening to the hasidic jews and
what's happening to blacks in some areas
it's it's horrendous
and you're so aware of it you're more
it's there it's constant
the news cycle is is 24 7. 24 hours a
day
so i think it's worse because i know
more about it now that i know things
that are happening across the world
open school week at school i go to
lynn's class
and i'm i call coming to class and i'm
waving with her and she's waving to me
and she's so pleased that her is it's
there
and so i listen to all the little
speeches the little kids give and we get
ready to leave when we use the back
door so we leave the back door and i've
got lin's hand
and we're watering she had this big afro
afros they had afros like you wouldn't
believe
and not only the afros they were in
style back then yes but they also had
dog hair in it
which meant you had half gray alpha and
when you comb the afros half the dog
hears it will come out
okay on the comb and then sometimes your
hair would be on the door
at any rate we're getting ready to leave
the classroom i've got linsen
holding her hand leaving the classroom
teacher looks at me and says whose
mother are you
okay she's darker than you that was the
wrong thing to say to me
i told them to stand back i'll be right
with her we went out in the hall i
backed this poor woman up into against
the wall
and by the time i was finished with her
she didn't know what to say
i reported her to the principal the
insensitivity of saying that in front of
a child
the sheer insensitivity lin didn't know
what happened
okay but whose mother are you and i'm
holding the kid's hand
anyway that was one of the experiences
so um i did some things growing up that
i didn't know how you might have viewed
them
whether you just thought it was weird
like when i took over the bathroom and
turned it into a dark room to make
well fortunately we had more than one
bathroom okay okay okay
so that was not a problem okay okay and
then
and then not only that you had a sign
outside the door right it's when you
were developing
nobody can use it so we had to complete
that yeah the sign said keep the door
closed i don't want the dark to leak out
so that was never a problem okay you
were very supportive
of my interest absolutely absolutely i
was supposed to without without
forcing it it just it was there it was
natural
that's what you wanted to do that was
fine by us but then you also had some
insights i didn't know that
you can get books from the remainder
table that's a thing that
you introduced me to right right like
for a dollar
right i bought we would go to the store
and buy all these used books for you
and in addition to that you that that
lamp that you have there oh on my desk
yeah the um
saturn lamp yeah we went shopping for
the some pot
all the parts yeah all the hardware
that's in the saturn are you remembering
we went to about four or five different
stores
because that lamp was in shop class and
everyone is making a pre-fabbed
design right from from a file drawer
right and i said i'm not going to make
that that i got my own ideas
right so i drew it but then i needed my
own hardware right and so then you drove
of course i couldn't drive in seventh
grade but you took me around
yeah we went to about three or four
different stores to find those pieces
right
yeah how did you maintain hope
throughout all of that on a daily basis
and through my religion i'm like
practicing catholic
through my religion there's always hope
well that's very um it's easy to give up
hope
i know i know i know i know i know
are you uh as practicing today as ever
before malachot
a la carte yeah catholic alacar right
okay ashes and palms
as they say is that right ash wednesday
palm sunday
yeah yeah so you still participate in
the christian rituals oh yes obviously
yes oh yes so for me as a scientist
i i was i was getting skeptical around
age 9 10 11 and so
it was just weird hearing someone tell
me under what conditions you go to hell
under what conditions you um so did it
concern you that i was drifting no i
just said be quiet and listen
and we'd still go to mass and you'd go
to mass yeah yes and you made your first
communion made your confirmation
right right i still go i mean i hadn't
you know it is what it is
so that's what it was right i said just
stay awake please
[Music]
by the way when some of those catholic
masses are very sleepy affairs
i know but that's what i think you love
that's the way i think you got your love
of candles from you so love them and
watch
look at the candles and i remember so
distinctly
when you guys used to go to day camp and
the first
day of day camp and i would be waiting
at the bus
and you wouldn't get off the bus and
neil was not on the bus i said where's
my child he went on this bus this
morning
so the driver would get up and find you
and sleeping in the back of the bus
so so every day you were the last one
off the bus because you were sleeping
once or twice i didn't realize that when
we were kneeling
at church you'd stretch out in the back
seat
in the pew and fall asleep and these
shoes are sticking up in the air like
this
i was like get up when did you start
learning from the three of us
from lynn me and steve was there some
point oh
my kids are old enough now they have
life experience that
informs you in your life or just never
well when you went off to your different
careers and left home
you we would talk all the time on the
telephone and you tell me what you were
doing and i tell you what we're doing
and we'd always get together for
holidays major events thanksgiving and
christmas
major major events we'd have all
extended relatives and
all these tables all over the place and
that's the way it was
and to this day we still have these
family gatherings the holland major
holidays except now you're just
counting off who who's died the year
that's right who's who's missing from
the table
and whenever i give thanks at these
large events i remember the person who
was there last year
and particularly of course dad right
okay so we went to our social media
fan base and asked if any of them had
questions for us
okay we did that this morning did you
really yes well they did i got we got
people who do this
okay okay so i have the list right here
okay okay
are you ready i'm ready okay okay this
one this
question is for me uh this is from
natalia rosa one of our patreon
supporters
there's a network of people who donate
monthly
to participate in some in
what this universe is that we're
creating
and help support the program so it's to
me what do you appreciate about your
mother
in guiding you through your early years
did she
ever dissuade you chasing certain dreams
or was she always encouraging and does
she have
mildly embarrassing tales to share of
young neil
i think we would all enjoy that lots of
love to mama tyson
well isn't that sweet that's very nice
that's very very nice
good do you have an embarrassing no
none that you would tell or just not
just i just i would shut you up
immediately when you started getting to
saying things that are inappropriate
we want to elevate them once in skyview
oh i don't know someplace
and and an indian guy got on with his
turban on
and you pulled me on he said what's
wrong with his head
oh cause i thought it was bandages
that's right
[Music]
but no i was never embarrassed by
anything okay so what you appreciate
most about your mother and guiding you
through your early years i would say
i didn't know this at the time i didn't
know to appreciate it at the time
but that every conversation every
conflict
had foundations in rational discussion
you did this why did you do this and
what
was your intent and here's the cause
this is not a good outcome
do it differently next time there was it
wasn't just do this because i say
because that's where does that lead you
and i wonder if that
promoted my early sense of curiosity
because if something happens in a
particular way you want to know the
reason for it
but if your whole life is do this
because i'm the adult and i know better
and you don't
do it then it's a life of of
following commands rather than a life of
exploring
what it is one should do and why so
where did you you and dad get this from
because we visit
friends parents and i see the parents
like whoa
i'm glad i don't live in this house whoa
well the father would be sitting at the
end of the table back in the day when
fathers were
you know patriarchs and no one would
say talk back to the father and no one
would
yes sir and no sir and i'm thinking
where's the conversation
he just said something that wasn't quite
right who is who's going to challenge
that
and i kept it to myself because i'm
visiting other families
but in our family everybody could say
anything to anybody basically
as long as you weren't insulting them
and insulting right i mean a lot of
still respectful but not
if you said something that wasn't quite
right i'm coming back at you
and then we we resolve that so i'd like
i appreciated that
in a low tone of voice yeah no one ever
raised their voice right plus
no one ever carried grudges that's for
sure you leave that table
you're loving each other right no matter
how many bought teams just you know
bought changes as a puerto rican word
for
confusion and stuff no matter how many
bocincias were at the table
you leave it at the table and go forth
and
and no you didn't dissuade anything
at all you and dad whatever we did it
was let's explore this
and so that was always fun and you'd
even take it another step
steps that we didn't know was a next
step to take right that's important
right because you had some sense of how
societies works and agencies work
and when i was attending classes
at the hayden planetarium in middle
school
and i took some advanced class for
adults of the youngest kid in the class
and i'd asked questions i think i was
more curious than the adults
right because they were just there i
think they just maybe wanted to learn a
few things but this is like my gosh this
is the universe
you excited because as excited as i am
you know i was like
12 or something well when you win
right and you were going on to high
school and you were
from junior high school it had been
recommended that you take advanced
physics at science high school
let me get to that in a minute okay so
in this episode
i'm taking a class and at the end
this man comes up to me who's in the
class and handed me his business card
right right and i don't know anything
about business cards
like what is this i don't know and then
i took it home and showed you
and he said he's director of education
at the explorers club
and we should call this and find out if
their opportunity i would have known to
do
to do that but you guys are very plugged
into i called that guy
immediately right and that's when i got
a scholarship and then i went to
africa to view a total eclipse and
because
to this day i would think like to thank
him again yeah vernon gray
you were not able to locate him uh i
i tried later on i don't know what
happened i would like to thank him
profusely
vernon that he opened for you was
fantastic
right yeah right i think he liked the
questions i asked
right like one of them was if
nothing comes out of a black hole the
light can't come out
because it travels the speed of light
and it's not fast enough to escape a
black hole
gravity moves at the speed of light so i
asked him how does gravity get out of
the black hole
so that the teacher didn't have an
answer to that but i think it impressed
this other guy
okay another question this is from
will j will jay's a patreon member
as a kid i quote accidentally made a
little chlorine gas
with an electrolysis experiment at home
did neil ever do anything similarly
salty
or kind of dangerous that you know of
not that i know of but yeah i was i was
not the chemist
so i didn't create any fires or burn
holes in the carpet right right or
anything like that right
i was mostly just optics tied up the
bathroom that's all and
with the dark room right right right
okay
so no yeah i didn't destroy anything
right i don't think
no you didn't yeah okay yeah so no
so there okay
to neil's mother do you remember the
trip to the hayden planetarium
when neal was nine because i speak of
this trip
what was he like before and after i
imagine the transformation
must have been incredible to witness
you've made no difference you were happy
you loved it and we made sure you went
back again
this is after you went outside the
museum started climbing the statue of
teddy roosevelt with the lions or
whatever is out there the lions it's the
that's the library everybody's got
statues out front here we got teddy we
got teddy out front
right no um it was just another new york
experience
this is all part of the learning lab
experiment
so you would know to go back because i
was excited by it
so that so that was a focusing
absolutely of repeated experience
exactly because otherwise we'd go to the
zoo or the aquarium or whatever else
and then it doesn't focus but now you
had an occasion to focus it absolutely
okay yeah because it wasn't so much an
instantaneous thing it was like wow
this universe is pretty good i wonder
how to continue to do this
right and then the binoculars and books
and so it's a it's a it's a
it's a slow burn but it's very real and
your first telescope
first telescope was two years after this
right right
so you who you both decided i should
have a telescope
well you were talking about a telescope
and you started making money by walking
dogs right
and we said if you get enough money for
the telescope we'll we'll
help you buy it so you got about 75
percent of the money and we put
the balance in and we went up we found
out where to go went all the way up to
new haven
okay that was my second telescope oh the
first telescope
was the one that dad helped me assemble
up in lexington
that one you guys bought and i didn't
that was a surprise to me yeah yeah that
was my 12th birthday yeah that we got
that is
that serious you did yeah you remembered
that it was like 50
telescopes right but that was enough i
can see the rings of saturn and the
craters on the moon
and the moons of jupiter and there's a
lot going on in that
and i and you and i then i outgrew it
right within two years or so and that's
when uh i had the money
from walking dogs right yeah that was
the glory days of dog walking you know
why
because you didn't have to clean up
after the dog you just walk and there's
poop everywhere last question from
patreon
and oh this is so neil could you
theoretically go back in time and
accidentally stop your
mother from meeting your father thus you
never being born at all
then again if you're never born at all
well then how would you go back and stop
your mother from meeting your father
tell them i don't know that that's
that's just i can't handle that
that's jonathan wax patreon member you
tell mr wax i can't handle that
i'm dealing with the hair now i'm trying
to make it from one day to the next
trying to put my feet on the floor every
morning and then 91 at an easy
that's why i'm hobbling around with a
cane so okay
okay so jonathan my mother don't play
that
well okay mom well thank you for
agreeing to this interview you're quite
welcome and thank you folks too
thank thanking our production staff here
i'm interested in seeing the final cut
okay um how about one last thing promise
for new parents out there or which
there's a generation
every day is there any
91 years of parenting wisdom you can
just
share well i can tell you this much i'm
i feel sorry for parents of today
because all you see even toddlers
walking around with hands held
objects in their hand and everybody's
clicking and everybody's clicking
they're not talking to each other
they're talking away from each other
they can be in the same room
corresponding with each other with these
dog gonna handle
handheld devices and i think a stop
should be put to it and
in the home particularly at mealtimes
and particularly in schools because
they're embarrassing each other
they're hurting each other it's a very
painful experience of some of these kids
and i think it's a tragedy
okay so that's what not to do that's
right can you have advice of what to do
yes listen to an educational program
such as star talk
such as nova go back to the old ways of
doing things
yes they can fool around with their
handhelds but not 100 percent of time
they walk up and down with them
often parents if they have kids who are
accomplished
they're very proud and they'll sort of
talk about him and
that's my boy that's my daughter that's
my thing
you never really behave that way never
ever
for us that's right like i do something
really great so that's nice
you know you're late for dinner
so i didn't view it as negative i just
viewed it as
these are my i'm following my interests
right and
i'm not doing it to get praise right and
nor did you offer praise
well yeah sometimes i praised you for
the specific things
particularly sometimes how you handle
people i'm always concerned about how
you handle people
how you talk to them mm-hmm uh but yes i
have praised you
no but so but in general i don't
remember
the household being one where you
or dad were continuously praising us
conte right yeah absolutely right okay
was there some thinking behind that
no we just let you do your own thing and
we we never talked about it
why because it was for us it was natural
if you are
if you're on a prescribed course and
you're sticking to it then we're happy
about that and we leave it alone
and another thing too sometimes i'm in a
group situation
and towards the end of the conversation
somebody might say to me
are you related to neil tyson this is
the end of the conversation
and then i say yes i'm his mother then
everybody gets older
we want to cruise once and we met two
people we spent a lot of time with them
a whole lot of time with them there's
one of these retirement cruises
okay and we spent a lot of time with
this couple
and on the last day we were out and
there were stars in the sky and i said
oh my son would love to see this
and she turned around she says
you're related to neil tyson you must be
and i thought she was going to faint
dead away but all the time we were there
i never mentioned your name
no that i i in retrospect that's a good
thing
yes i think so too just historically
because
what it means is the the interest is
sort of genuinely nurtured from within
it's not i'm not doing it because i'm
after your praise
right right and how many people are out
there where everything they're doing is
just so that their parents can say nice
things about them right
but that was never even on the table
right it just wasn't
really there okay so that being said
of all the things i've done is there
something that you
think most about or most highly your
books my books i think your books will
be a part of your legacy
oh okay programs you know can fade away
but your books i think will carry on
okay and particularly in foreign
languages i think that's very important
yeah yeah they're good yeah so they've
enjoyed many translations yes
yes so i think that's very important and
i'm very pleased about that
and in my very latest book
letters from an astrophysicist right
it's dedicated to you and dan
oh that's nice i don't know if you knew
that that's nice no i didn't and the
dedication to you was
it was a thank you for first teaching me
how to say what i mean when i write
right and i remembered we would write
letters together to
achieve certain things it could be
anything a product failure and you had
to go back and get a
refund or whatever and it required a
letter to the customer service
there was an entire way that words would
go to a page to communicate an idea
an intent in search of a conclusion
and i got all that from you yeah yeah so
where did you get it from
i don't know it was just there was it a
lifetime of complaining
to the world that stuff didn't go the
way well i do write good
complaint letters there's no two ways
about is who what why when and where to
mess the end of that so i dedicated my
next book to you okay
letters from an astrophysicist to you
and dad okay
and so to my mother who
first taught me how to write with
meaning and impact
and to my father whose life experience
navigating people places and things
conferred upon me the necessary wisdom
to navigate a life of my own oh how nice
that's nice neil that's very nice
dad would have liked that very much yeah
that's nice thank you you're quite
welcome mom
thank you neil son
so this has been a very very
very special edition of star talk and i
want to thank my special special guest
mom i agree
[Laughter]
for agreeing to sit down and and be
grilled by her son
for this episode thanks for tuning in
and as always
i bid you to keep looking up